Alice: 5秒
Alice: 5 seconds
Jake: 来
Jake: Come on
Jake: 来露西开始了吧
Jake: Alright, Lucia, let's start
Jake: 啊好好
Jake: Ah, okay
Jake: 那我们后边先看
Jake: Let's watch first
Alice: 看这个好茂盛
Alice: Look how lush this is
Lucia: 我说好的哦
Lucia: I told you it's good
Tasha: 他真好
Tasha: He's really nice
Jake: 好我们有很多东西
Jake: Alright, we have a lot of stuff
Jake: 稍等一下
Jake: Hold on a sec
Jake: 谢谢
Jake: Thanks
Alice: 这是别人那啥的
Alice: This is from someone else
Tasha: 别人的庄园
Tasha: Someone else's estate
Jake: 可以走那一边
Jake: We can go that way
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Hmm
Katrina:  这好像有点重
Katrina: This feels kinda heavy
Katrina:  我拿这个
Katrina: I'll take this one
Katrina:  哇这个更
Katrina: Wow, this one is even
Katrina:  这个有点重我拿不了
Katrina: This one is a bit heavy, I can't carry it
Katrina:  我们俩一起行吗
Lucia: 哇这个真的好重
Lucia: Wow, this is really heavy
Lucia: 对，咱俩一起
Lucia: Yeah, let's do it together
Lucia: 要不可能里面饮料比较多
Lucia: Maybe there are a lot of drinks inside
Katrina: 对
Katrina: Yeah
Jake: 我来吧
Jake: Let me do it
Lucia: 这个，还能拿动吗，
Lucia: Can you still carry this?
Jake: 喔 这人怎么这个样子
Jake: Whoa, why is this person like this
Alice:这个撒了
Alice: This one spilled
Lucia: 可以把这个这个 我手拿着
Lucia: Can you take this? I'll hold it
Tasha: 眼睛头疼不疼
Tasha: Does your head hurt?
Tasha: 小心点啊
Tasha: Be careful
Lucia: 小心
Lucia: Watch out
Tasha: 他他的摄像头
Tasha: His camera
Jake: 我我我头疼
Jake: My head hurts
Jake: 哎呀头确实疼
Jake: Ah, my head really hurts
Jake:还有
Jake: Anything else?
Alice: 还有
Alice: Anything else?
Alice: 还有我们的司机  跟蒜苗
Alice: We still have our driver and the garlic sprouts
Tasha: 我我
Tasha: I, I
Jake: 好谢谢谢谢你
Jake: Alright, thank you, thank you
Jake:这是什么
Jake: What's this?
Lucia: 没没没掉吧
Lucia: It didn't fall, right?
Tasha: 哎蒜
Tasha: Oh, garlic.
Katrina:  哎呀
Katrina: Oh no.
Alice: 这个不是我们的吧
Alice: This isn't ours, right?
Tasha: 不是都不是了
Tasha: Nope, none of it is.
Alice: 哦走吧OK
Alice: Oh, let's go, OK.
Lucia: 哇这个真的好重
Lucia: Wow, this is really heavy.
Katrina:  往哪走来着
Katrina: Where are we going again?
Jake: 走
Jake: Let's go.
Alice:嗯熏人
Alice: Ugh, it's suffocating.
Alice: 哎其实我们隔着这个也能够一把
Alice: Actually, we can still reach it from here.
Tasha: 怎么开商务座的都要打领带
Tasha: Why do business class people always wear ties?
Tasha: 穿皮裤啊
Tasha: And leather pants?
Tasha: 哦不，穿，穿西装裤
Tasha: Oh no, I mean, dress pants.
Jake: 不知道哎
Jake: No idea.
Alice: 我觉得这个小紫花也可以
Alice: I think this little purple flower is nice too.
Alice: 你看挺好看的
Alice: Look, it's pretty.
Tasha: 是的嘞
Tasha: Yeah, it is.
Alice:他把我这个偷
Alice: He stole this from me.
Alice: 呃拿花
Alice: Uh, picked a flower.
Katrina:  我刚刚搜了一下
Katrina: I just searched it.
Katrina:  那个世界地球日的海报他很多
Katrina: The Earth Day poster, there are many.
Katrina:  淘宝上都是发的是那种网盘
Katrina: They're all on Taobao, shared on cloud drives.
Katrina:  那咱自己打印也行
Katrina: We can print it ourselves.
Alice: 狗狗碎碎的
Alice: The dog tore it up.
Tasha: 呃前面一个吧
Tasha: Uh, the one in front.
Tasha: 这个像那棵树的那个地方
Tasha: The one that looks like that tree.
Alice:你这个小花妆起来好好看啊
Alice: Your little flower makeup looks so good.
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Alice:哼哼
Alice: Hmm-hmm.
Jake: 这个像嗯
Jake: This looks like, hmm.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Tasha: 很多
Tasha: A lot.
Jake:认不得家了
Jake: Can't recognize home anymore.
Jake: 世界地球是啥啥啥
Jake: What is Earth Day again?
Jake: 忘了啊
Jake: Forgot.
Katrina:  啊就是那个海报
Katrina: Oh, it's that poster.
Katrina:  我搜到的都是网盘
Katrina: All I found were cloud drive links.
Katrina:  就是那种虚拟的
Katrina: Just virtual stuff.
Katrina:  那就是自己打印呗
Katrina: So you mean we print it ourselves?
Jake: 哦哦哦OK啊
Jake: Oh, oh, oh, OK.
Jake: 可以啊你
Jake: Sure, you can do that.
Katrina:  没有单独的
Katrina: There's no separate one.
Alice: 们的房子不是绿色的吗
Alice: Isn't our house green?
Tasha: 蓝色
Tasha: Blue.
Tasha:  蓝绿色
Tasha: Blue-green.
Alice:这个吗
Alice: This one?
Alice: 这个颜色吗
Alice: This color?
Katrina:  是这里吧
Katrina: Is it here?
Tasha: 但感觉又走错了
Tasha: But it feels like we took the wrong turn again.
Alice: 你们不应该是从那个吗
Alice: Weren't you supposed to come from that direction?
Jake: 对和昨天一样
Jake: Yes, just like yesterday.
Lucia: 这个这个这个
Lucia: This, this, this.
Katrina:  咋啦
Katrina: What?
Jake: 里边水比较重是吧
Jake: The water inside is quite heavy, right?
Lucia: 对就是哈哈哈
Lucia: Yes, exactly, haha.
Lucia: 我得稍微放一下调整一下我的手
Lucia: I need to adjust my hand a bit.
Jake: 要不我们极限一换一
Jake: How about we do a one-for-one swap?
Katrina:  咋啦
Katrina: What?
Jake: 我们极限一换一
Jake: We'll do a one-for-one swap.
Lucia: 哎你一只手提这个提得动吗
Lucia: Hey, can you lift this with one hand?
小汾： 你
Katrina: You
Jake: 我试一下我试一下我试一下
Jake: Let me try, let me try, let me try.
Lucia: 会不会太重了
Lucia: Isn't it too heavy?
Jake: 好奇一下这个有多重
Jake: Just curious how heavy this is.
Lucia: 真的真的很重
Lucia: It's really, really heavy.
Katrina: 你健身吗
Katrina: Do you work out?
Lucia: 小心
Lucia: Be careful.
Jake:撞到你头了
Jake: Almost hit your head.
Lucia: 没事没事
Lucia: It's fine, it's fine.
Lucia: 咱俩都在头疼一下了
Lucia: Both of us are having headaches now.
Jake: 那可不
Jake: Isn't that true?
Katrina: 你健身吗
Katrina: Do you work out?
Lucia: 要不你把这个袋子给我们俩
Lucia: How about you give us the bag?
Jake: 你你你
Jake: You, you, you.
Lucia: 能提动那个吗
Lucia: Can you lift that?
Jake: 你可能
Jake: Maybe you
Jake: 你可能觉得这个好像比这个更重
Jake: Maybe you think this one is heavier than that one.
Lucia: 是这样吗
Lucia: Is that so?
Lucia: 这个好像也挺重的
Lucia: This seems pretty heavy too.
Katrina:  呃 是的
Katrina: Uh, yes.
Lucia: 是的但好像比刚那个稍微好一点点
Lucia: Yes, but it seems a bit better than the last one.
Jake: OK行
Jake: OK, got it.
Lucia: 走咱加快步伐
Lucia: Let's go, let's pick up the pace.
Jake: 极限一换一
Jake: Extreme one-for-one.
Alice: 这个给我吧
Alice: Give this to me.
Lucia: 谢谢您辛苦了
Lucia: Thank you, much appreciated.
Jake: 健身我是两年前健
Jake: I started working out two years ago.
Jake: 我到新加坡之后就不健了
Jake: I stopped once I got to Singapore.
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Jake: 因为
Jake: Because...
Alice:右右右
Alice: Right, right, right.
Jake: 右边右边啊
Jake: To the right, to the right.
Lucia: 因为工作比较忙嘛
Lucia: Because work has been quite busy.
Jake: 因为健身房有点远
Jake: Because the gym is a bit far.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Jake: 就是作为一个P人吧
Jake: As an average person...
Jake: 就健身房他不在楼底下我应该很难去
Jake: If the gym isn't just downstairs, it's hard for me to go.
Katrina: 是这样的
Katrina: That's how it is.
Lucia: 是这样的哈哈
Lucia: That's how it is, haha.
Lucia: 任何东西不离我很近我一般都很难去
Lucia: Anything that's not very close to me is hard for me to go to.
Jake: 在这个里边
Jake: It's in here.
Tasha: 应该把小米装
Tasha: Should put the Xiaomi...
Tasha: 装小米烤箱的那个袋子带着的
Tasha: Put it in the bag that came with the Xiaomi oven.
Jake: 什么袋子
Jake: What bag?
Tasha: 那个大袋子啊
Tasha: That big bag.
Jake: 小米烤箱
Jake: Xiaomi oven.
Jake: 还有个线是吧
Jake: There's also a cord, right?
Katrina: 好香啊是谁在烤肉呢
Katrina: Smells so good, who's grilling meat?
Katrina: 这个
Katrina: This...
Lucia: 我们的有有密码吗
Lucia: Do we have a password for ours?
Jake: 有密码但是我记不住
Jake: There's a password, but I can't remember it.
Lucia: 嗯哈哈
Lucia: Hmm, haha.
Lucia: 那您来说
Lucia: Then you tell me.
Alice: 呃我要查下手机
Alice: Uh, I need to check my phone.
Katrina: 没事我看
Katrina: It's okay, I'll look.
Jake: 这个时候手机如果能告诉你
Jake: If the phone can tell you at this moment...
Lucia: 但是我记住了
Lucia: But I remembered it.
Tasha: 不是这么说的吗
Tasha: Isn't it said like this?
Lucia: 问下西瑞
Lucia: Ask Shure.
Jake: 哦但他说的好像是但他记住了
Jake: Oh, but he said it seems like he remembered.
Jake: 哈哈我没有记住
Jake: Haha, I didn't remember.
Lucia: 这个要是有语音功能就好了
Lucia: It would be great if this had a voice function.
Jake: 对问问他
Jake: Yeah, ask him.
Lucia: 我发现这个摄像头会发出彩虹光哎
Lucia: I noticed this camera emits rainbow light.
Jake: 是的是的
Jake: Yes, yes.
Jake: 再再再摁一次那个3
Jake: Press that 3 again.
Jake: 那个3再摁一下
Lucia: 那我我
Lucia: Then I'll...
Jake:三三
Jake: Three, three.
Lucia: 怎样能把它删掉1好像没有
Lucia: How can I delete it? It seems there's no 1.
Jake: 不就不用
Jake: No, you don't need to.
Jake: 不用重来
Jake: No need to redo it.
Jake: 就就是你直接重来就行
Jake: Just start over directly.
Jake: 他就算最后一位
Jake: He'll just be the last one.
Lucia: 925 对OK
Lucia: 925, right, OK.
Lucia: 我们一块来吧
Lucia: Let's do it together.
Lucia: 这真的太重了
Lucia: This is really heavy.
Jake: 就我们就这什么味道
Jake: So we... What's that smell?
Katrina:  咋啦
Katrina: What’s up?
Lucia: 不咋了这门不太灵活
Lucia: Nothing, this door is not very flexible.
Lucia: 没事开到大家能进来的程度就行了
Lucia: It's fine, just open it enough for everyone to get in.
Jake: 你怕这个邻居听不见是吧
Jake: You're afraid the neighbor can't hear, right?
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Mm-hmm.
Lucia: 现在就放一下
Lucia: Let’s put it down now.
Lucia: 一会大家一起收拾一收拾
Lucia: We'll all clean up together later.
Katrina:  哇哇赛博
Katrina: Wow, cyber...
Katrina:  赛博世纪
Katrina: Cyber century.
Katrina:  给拍一个
Katrina: Take a picture.
Tasha: 往里面放一点
Tasha: Put it in a bit more.
Tasha: 哇这个真的来放不了了
Tasha: Wow, this really can't fit anymore.
Katrina:  真的很理想
Katrina: It's really ideal.
Lucia: 真的很赛博
Lucia: It's really cyber.
Lucia: 您的卧室真的很赛博是吧
Lucia: Your bedroom is really cyber, right?
Jake: 晚上就是这个样子
Jake: It looks like this at night.
Jake: 因为怕这个关掉之后数据就倒不过去
Jake: Because I'm afraid if I turn it off, the data won't transfer over.
Jake: 对就得开着
Jake: Yes, it needs to stay on.
Jake: 然后突然惊醒的看一眼哦
Jake: Then suddenly wake up and take a look, oh,
Jake: 还在传哈哈哈
Jake: it's still transmitting, hahaha.
Lucia: 我可以在你的小桌子上玩2077吗
Lucia: Can I play 2077 on your small table?
Katrina: 太真实了
Katrina: That's too real.
Lucia: 哈哈沉浸式玩游戏
Lucia: Haha, immersive gaming.
Jake: 是
Jake: Yes.
Katrina:  我要记一下我们还有什么东西没买
Katrina: I need to note down what we haven't bought yet.
Katrina:  笔呢
Katrina: Where's the pen?
Tasha: 我们先把要放进冰箱的挑出来
Tasha: Let's first sort out what needs to go into the fridge.
Lucia: 好的
Lucia: Okay.
Tasha: 把
Tasha: Put...
Katrina:  这个笔呢
Katrina: This pen...
Katrina:  谁看见了
Katrina: Who saw it?
Jake: 笔我带上去了我
Jake: I took the pen upstairs.
Jake: 再带上去
Jake: I'll take it up again.
Lucia: 哪瓶水是我的来着
Lucia: Which bottle of water is mine?
Lucia: 我们应该没
Lucia: We probably didn't...
Lucia: 我应该没
Lucia: I probably didn't...
Lucia: 拿出去喝两口
Lucia: Take it out and drink a few sips.
Lucia: 我想喝口水
Lucia: I want to drink some water.
Lucia: 没有没开的水
Lucia: There's no unopened water.
Lucia: 呦这这对
Lucia: Oh, this, this right.
Tasha: 嗯嗯没事看看
Tasha: Hmm, it's okay, take a look.
Tasha: 咦是吧
Tasha: Eh, is it?
Lucia: 什么情况啊
Lucia: What's going on?
Jake: 啊要不砍了吧
Lucia: 对他好像打不开
Lucia: Yeah, it seems like it won't open.
Jake: 一个大刀把它给剪了
Jake: Use a big knife to cut it.
Lucia: 哦开了开了
Lucia: Oh, it opened, it opened.
Lucia: 有点紧那个
Lucia: It's a bit tight, that one.
Lucia: 记得
Lucia: Remember,
Jake:这个
Jake: This...
Tasha: 水果水果放一起
Tasha: Put the fruits together,
Tasha: 蔬菜放一起对
Tasha: and the vegetables together, right.
Lucia: 没开封的饮料其实可以先放在外面
Lucia: Unopened drinks can actually be left outside for now.
Lucia: 是咱们现在因为东西比较多就不要
Lucia: Because we have a lot of stuff now, so let's not...
Alice: 楼上是不是还有热不要钱
Alice: There's still heat upstairs, isn't there?
Katrina:  那我把对饮料放楼上去
Katrina: Then I'll put the drinks upstairs.
Lucia: 楼上有个冰箱
Lucia: There's a fridge upstairs.
Jake: 等一下先
Jake: Wait a second.
Lucia: 先把先把先把必须放冰箱的放进去
Lucia: First, put the things that need to be in the fridge inside.
Jake:先把冰放进去
Jake: Put the ice in first.
Lucia: 然后再考虑别的
Lucia: Then we'll think about the rest.
Lucia: 冰
Lucia: Ice.
Jake:就是要放冰冻的
Jake: We need to freeze it.
Jake: 冷冻的哦
Jake: Freeze it, okay?
Katrina:  还有个蓝莓是吗
Katrina: There's a blueberry too, right?
Katrina:  冷冻啊这个是需要放冰箱的
Katrina: This needs to be in the freezer.
Tasha: 还有一盒草莓呢
Tasha: There's also a box of strawberries.
Tasha: 啊哦在这
Tasha: Oh, here it is.
Tasha: 哦吓我一跳
Tasha: Oh, it scared me.
Katrina:  这个是必须放冰箱的
Katrina: This needs to be in the fridge.
Lucia: 这个是放冷藏室
Lucia: This goes in the fridge section.
Lucia: 冷冻室
Lucia: Freezer section.
Katrina: 冷藏吧
Katrina: Fridge, maybe?
Katrina:  冷冻冷藏
Katrina: Freezer, fridge.
Alice:冷藏
Alice: Fridge.
Alice: 冷冻这个冷藏有0度吗
Alice: Is this freezer cold enough for the fridge?
Alice: 我怎么感觉这温度不太够
Alice: I feel like the temperature isn't enough.
Katrina:  我把饮料集中放二楼哎
Katrina: I'll put the drinks on the second floor.
Jake: 你们不是有那个测温的吗
Jake: Don't you guys have a temperature tester?
Jake: 测温有用吗
Jake: Does the temperature tester work?
Tasha: 要要干嘛
Tasha: What do we need it for?
Jake: 测冰箱多少度
Jake: To check the fridge temperature.
Lucia: 万一不够的话
Lucia: In case it's not cold enough.
Lucia: 那个肉也可以放冷冻室
Lucia: The meat can go in the freezer.
Lucia: 然后尽快吃
Lucia: And eat it soon.
Lucia: 只要它上面结的霜不要太多就行
Lucia: As long as there's not too much frost on it.
Tasha: 这放两瓶鲜牛奶刚刚好
Tasha: Two bottles of fresh milk fit just right.
Tasha: 这个可以拿出来了
Tasha: This can come out.
Alice: 鲜牛奶
Alice: Fresh milk.
Katrina:  这这个要不扔了吧
Katrina: Should we throw this out?
Tasha: 这个可以拿出来
Tasha: This can come out.
Katrina:  烤鸭这个昨天晚上
Katrina: The roast duck from last night.
Tasha: 我天哪冰箱里面放菜说我不能接受
Tasha: Oh my god, I can't accept putting veggies in the fridge.
Katrina:  而且没有盖保鲜膜
Katrina: And it's not even covered with plastic wrap.
Jake:确实
Jake: True.
Katrina:  扔了吧
Katrina: Let's throw it out.
Jake: 丢吧来
Jake: Yeah, toss it.
Katrina:  这酒啥的我放二楼吧
Katrina: I'll put the alcohol on the second floor.
Tasha: 行
Tasha: Okay.
Katrina:  我想这一楼先做饭是在一楼吧
Katrina: I think we should cook on the first floor first.
Lucia: 蛋要放冰箱吧应该
Lucia: The eggs should go in the fridge, right?
Katrina: 完美
Katrina: Perfect.
Jake: 呃好
Jake: Uh, okay.
Jake: 是吗芒果是给人
Jake: Are the mangoes for eating or...
Jake: 吃的还是
Jake: ...what?
Tasha: 对我做甜品的
Tasha: Yeah, they're for making dessert.
Lucia: 那这个呢
Lucia: What about this?
Jake: 那为什么要6个呀
Jake: Why do we need six of them?
Tasha: 我只是觉得6个比较划算
Tasha: I just thought six was more economical.
Jake: 哦我以为你数了6个人呢
Jake: Oh, I thought you counted six people.
Lucia: 一人一个
Lucia: One for each person.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 呃今晚就把它吃掉
Lucia: Uh, let's eat them all tonight.
Jake: 对对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah.
Lucia: 那这个这个
Lucia: What about this one, this one?
Lucia: 这个菠萝是今天晚上吃的
Lucia: Is this pineapple for tonight?
Lucia: 还是要用的
Lucia: Or for later?
Tasha: 呃今天晚上吃的啊
Tasha: Uh, it's for tonight.
Lucia: 那要不就放外面
Lucia: Then let's leave it out.
Lucia: 反正今天晚上要吃
Lucia: We're eating it tonight anyway.
Jake: 我们点个外卖吧
Jake: Let's order takeout.
Lucia: 好嘞
Lucia: Got it.
Tasha: 还有一瓶鲜奶呢
Tasha: There's still a bottle of fresh milk.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Alice:还需要
Alice: Do we still need...
Alice: 还有肉吗
Alice: ...any more meat?
Tasha: 没有肉了啊
Tasha: No more meat.
Katrina:  还有虾滑
Katrina: There's still shrimp paste.
Katrina:  等一下还还有一瓶虾滑
Katrina: Wait, there's still another bottle of shrimp paste.
Katrina:  放哪里啊
Katrina: Where should I put it?
Katrina:  我来放
Katrina: I'll handle it.
Tasha: 还有一瓶鲜奶呢
Tasha: There's still a bottle of fresh milk.
Lucia: 嗯啊西瓜
Lucia: Hmm, ah, watermelon.
Tasha: 牛奶
Tasha: Milk.
Alice: 就是怎么只剩一个了
Alice: Why is there only one left?
Tasha: 哎怎么只剩一瓶牛奶了啊
Tasha: Hey, why is there only one bottle of milk left?
Lucia: 那那里那里那里还有一个袋子
Lucia: There's still another bag over there.
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh
Lucia: 没事
Lucia: It's okay.
Lucia: 我来拿吧
Lucia: I'll get it.
Tasha: 你
Tasha: You...
Jake:错了错了错了
Jake: Wrong, wrong, wrong.
Jake: 对不起对不起对不起对不起
Jake: I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
Tasha: 放这的
Tasha: Put it here.
Tasha: 因为感觉这样子一定要放在一起
Tasha: Because I feel like it should be put together like this.
Tasha: 就会很好看
Tasha: It will look great.
Tasha: 对所以我一直在找他
Tasha: Yeah, so I've been looking for him.
Alice:蛋是不是放这
Alice: Should the eggs be placed here?
Tasha: 嗯对
Tasha: Yes.
Alice:这有个蛋篓
Alice: There's an egg basket here.
Lucia: 这里还有一盒蛋
Lucia: There's another box of eggs here.
Tasha: 这盒蛋是可食用蛋
Tasha: This box of eggs is edible.
Tasha: 可生吃蛋
Tasha: They can be eaten raw.
Alice: 这个
Alice: This one...
Tasha: 直接这样吧
Tasha: Just like this.
Alice: 哇哦
Alice: Wow.
Tasha: 还可以嗯
Tasha: It's fine, yeah.
Alice: 这底下我觉得可以利用一下
Alice: I think we can use the space at the bottom.
Tasha: 可以先放这
Tasha: We can put this here first.
Jake: 你们在采购之前
Jake: Before you guys went shopping...
Jake: 有人仔细的看过冰箱吗
Jake: Did anyone take a good look at the fridge?
Katrina:  没有咋啦
Katrina: No, why?
Lucia: 但是需要的话
Lucia: But if needed...
Lucia: 咱们可以现在上仔细的看一下
Lucia: We can take a good look now.
Lucia: 那个没用了的冰箱
Lucia: The fridge that's not used...
Lucia: 还没用到的冰箱啊
Lucia: The one that's not used yet?
Jake: 也不用也不用
Jake: No need, no need.
Jake: 就是就就
Jake: It's just that...
Jake: 你们其实也没有看冰箱
Jake: You guys didn't actually look at the fridge.
Jake: 大概也就知道怎么回事了
Jake: You probably get the idea.
Lucia: 呃怎么回事
Lucia: Um, what idea?
Jake: 就是大概
Jake: Just roughly...
Jake: 呃我们装多少东西啊
Jake: How much stuff we can fit in it.
Lucia: 哦这个能放吗
Lucia: Oh, can this fit?
Tasha: 有一个估算吧
Tasha: We have an estimate.
Jake: 可能有吧
Jake: Maybe.
Jake: 蟹黄拌饭
Jake: Crab roe rice.
Jake: 肉蟹堡
Jake: Crab burger.
Jake: 春饼
Jake: Spring roll.
Tasha: 还有一盒草莓呢
Tasha: There's also a box of strawberries.
Lucia: 呃是不是在那里面
Lucia: Uh, is it in there?
Lucia: 没有吗
Lucia: No?
Lucia: 哎那那边那个也已经拿出来了
Lucia: Oh, that one over there is already taken out.
Jake: 火锅底料
Jake: Hotpot base.
Lucia: 倒是还有一盒蓝莓不过
Lucia: There's still a box of blueberries though.
Tasha: 蓝莓放在这
Tasha: Put the blueberries here.
Tasha: 我嗯还还有一盒草莓呢
Tasha: I, um, still have another box of strawberries.
Katrina:  这只有一盒
Katrina: There's only one box.
Katrina: 喏，那里
Katrina: Look, there.
Lucia: 噢
Lucia: Oh.
Tasha: 天呐就跟瞎了一样
Tasha: Oh my god, it's like we're blind.
Katrina:  是的
Katrina: 视角是这样的
Katrina: The perspective is like this.
Tasha: 这个是不是也是常温就可以
Tasha: Can this also be kept at room temperature?
Jake:对啊对啊
Jake: Yeah, yeah.
Lucia: 这个我们拿的时候是常温的
Lucia: We took it at room temperature.
Jake:对啊放外边
Jake: Yeah, keep it outside.
Lucia: 你看那个密封的
Lucia: Look, it's sealed.
Jake:放外边放哪呢
Jake: Where should we keep it outside?
Lucia: 扔个垃圾
Lucia: Just throw it away.
Lucia: 哎这不是垃圾桶吗
Lucia: Isn't this the trash can?
Jake: 是垃圾桶
Jake: It is the trash can.
Jake: 但是 呃
Jake: But, uh...
Lucia: 他他他
Lucia: He, he, he...
Alice:那个内胆
Alice: The liner...
Jake:哦哦哦
Jake: Oh, oh, oh.
Alice:用来醒花了
Alice: It's used for waking up flowers.
Jake: 就这个已经被改装了
Jake: This has been modified.
Tasha: 改良了
Tasha: Improved.
Jake:给你看
Jake: Let me show you.
Jake: 改良成那个样子
Jake: Modified like this.
Jake: 哎改良完了
Jake: It's all modified.
Katrina: 我把饮料都放二楼了
Katrina: I put all the drinks on the second floor.
Lucia: 是这样的吗
Lucia: Is it like this?
Jake: 改完了是吧
Jake: It's modified, right?
Alice: 他们用过了
Alice: They've used it.
Jake: 他们原来把这个当作
Jake: They originally used this as...
Jake: 这个装花的容器啊
Jake: This container for flowers
Katrina:  我洗过了已经
Katrina: I've already washed it.
Lucia: sorry
Lucia: Sorry.
Lucia: 这这个魔芋丝和这些
Lucia: This konjac silk and these
Lucia: 这些是不是也是放冰箱的
Lucia: Should these also be put in the fridge?
Alice: 是的是的
Alice: Yes, yes.
Tasha: 这个葱姜蒜组合放外面就行了
Tasha: This combination of green onions, ginger, and garlic can be left outside.
Lucia: 对葱姜蒜可以放外面
Lucia: Yes, green onions, ginger, and garlic can be left outside.
Lucia: 里面嗯
Lucia: Inside, um...
Katrina: 嗯哼哼哼
Katrina: Mm-hmm.
Tasha: 一不一样的
Tasha: Different.
Alice: 不样的品种
Alice: Different varieties.
Lucia: OK
Lucia: OK.
Tasha: 这个鸡蛋放哪里呢
Tasha: Where should we put these eggs?
Tasha: 哎呦这个厨房好小呀
Tasha: Oh, this kitchen is so small.
Alice: 这这这置物架
Alice: This, this, this shelf.
Alice: 置物架
Alice: Shelf.
Alice: 感觉他在哪里都不好看
Alice: It feels like it doesn't look good anywhere.
Lucia: 要一下 要一下也行
Lucia: We can use it.
Lucia: 这个会坏的这么快吗
Lucia: Does it spoil this quickly?
Alice: 昨天到现在都快24小时
Alice: It's been almost 24 hours since yesterday.
Alice:赶紧给它喝了不得了
Alice: We should drink it quickly.
Tasha: 因为
Tasha: Because...
Lucia: 咱今天晚上把它喝了要不
Lucia: Should we drink it tonight?
Tasha: 嗯，不要再放了
Tasha: Yeah, don't keep it any longer.
Jake: 这玻璃隔音确实一般
Jake: This glass soundproofing is really average.
Jake: 丢掉了
Jake: Thrown away.
Katrina:  你那个蛋挞皮跟芋泥是怎么弄的芋圆
Katrina: How did you make that egg tart crust and taro balls?
Alice: 芋头就行
Alice: Just taro.
Katrina:  买了吗
Katrina: Did you buy it?
Alice:没有没有
Alice: No, no.
Tasha: 我挑好了
Tasha: I picked it out.
Katrina:  外送还是快递的
Katrina: Delivery or courier?
Tasha: 呃快递的
Tasha: Uh, courier.
Katrina: 就是你买的是吧
Katrina: So you bought it, right?
Katrina:  蛋挞皮跟那个芋头
Katrina: The egg tart crust and taro.
Tasha: 挑好了还没下单呢
Tasha: I picked it out but haven't ordered it yet.
Katrina:  哦我给你寄一下
Katrina: Oh, I'll send it to you.
Tasha: 还有展架
Tasha: And the display rack.
Jake:就帮我这个
Jake: Just help me with this.
Tasha: 扒拉一下
Tasha: Give it a push.
Jake:哎
Jake: Hey.
Alice:想换个鞋
Alice: Want to change my shoes.
Jake: 看看还有什么垃圾我一起扔出去
Jake: Let's see what other trash we have to throw out.
Jake: 这个得是垃圾
Jake: This must be trash.
Tasha: 对哦这个时候应该派出我们的
Tasha: Yeah, at this time we should send out our...
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Jake:哦吼吼
Jake: Oh ho ho.
Lucia: 吼有道理
Lucia: Makes sense.
Lucia: 对对对
Lucia: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Lucia: 先看一下一会把就是该扔的都扔了
Lucia: Let's first see what needs to be thrown out.
Lucia: 然后再擦
Lucia: Then clean up.
Katrina:  没有买时钟
Katrina: Didn't buy a clock.
Lucia: 还有没有啥要扔的
Lucia: Is there anything else to throw out?
Tasha: 没有买什么
Tasha: Didn't buy what?
Katrina: 时钟
Katrina: A clock.
Alice: 有那个厨房
Alice: There's that kitchen...
Jake:快递
Jake: Delivery.
Katrina:  快递就是一个普通的钟就行了
Katrina: The delivery is just a regular clock.
Jake: 对嗯
Jake: Yes, hmm.
Lucia: 你透气啊
Lucia: Are you breathing okay?
Katrina:  要挂的吗
Katrina: Do you want it to hang?
Katrina:  还是摆的
Katrina: Or is it white?
Jake: 呃我来买这个就好
Jake: Uh, I can buy it.
Tasha: 为什么要买时钟
Tasha: Why buy a clock?
Katrina:  我不知道他这些啊
Katrina: I don't know about these things.
Jake: 因为要计时
Jake: Because we need to time it.
Katrina: 你要买啥
Katrina: What do you want to buy?
Tasha:那个 呃
Tasha: That, uh...
Tasha: 盒子
Tasha: Box.
Lucia: 啥盒子
Lucia: What box?
Tasha: 就是甜品的不同的盒子
Tasha: Just different boxes for desserts.
Tasha: 对甜品盒
Tasha: Yes, dessert boxes.
Tasha: 行就这么多应该就这行
Tasha: Alright, that should be enough.
Katrina: 应该这就行
Katrina: That should be enough.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Lucia: 其他的应该收拾的差不多
Lucia: Everything else should be pretty much cleaned up.
Jake:扔完了是吧
Jake: Thrown away, right?
Jake: 那我出去扔掉
Jake: Then I'll take it out.
Lucia: 这俩袋子
Lucia: These two bags.
Lucia: 可以留着就这两天在倒垃圾用
Lucia: You can keep it for the next couple of days to use for trash.
Jake: 那个是什么
Jake: What's that?
Lucia: 微传
Lucia: Microtransmission.
Tasha: 保鲜膜
Tasha: Cling film.
Lucia: 你说这个吗
Lucia: Are you talking about this?
Lucia: 呃这个
Lucia: Uh, this.
Alice: 那个鲜花的
Alice: The one for flowers.
Tasha: 营养剂
Tasha: Nutrient.
Lucia: 鲜花的营养液
Lucia: Flower nutrient solution.
Alice:可以把它扔了啊
Alice: You can throw it away.
Alice: 不用也行
Alice: It's okay not to use it.
Katrina:  倒进去要不要
Katrina: Should we pour it in?
Jake: 啊不用了
Jake: Ah, no need.
Lucia: 这个需要用吗
Lucia: Do we need to use this?
Lucia: 不用就可以不用哦
Lucia: If we don't need it, we can just not use it.
Tasha: 用的话花会活的更久
Tasha: If you use it, the flowers will last longer.
Katrina:  那往里面倒一点我
Katrina: Then pour a bit in, I'll do it.
Katrina:  来倒哈哈
Katrina: Let me pour, haha.
Jake: 那就不用了
Jake: Then no need.
Lucia: 那就随便了
Lucia: Then whatever.
Lucia: 我来倒吧
Lucia: I'll pour it then.
Jake: 打了起来
Jake: Started fighting.
Jake: 扎马斯
Jake: Zamas.
Tasha: 打起来打起来
Tasha: Fight, fight.
Jake: 喜欢打起来
Jake: Love to fight.
Katrina: 我们什么时候打起来他就高兴
Katrina:  有素材了
Katrina: Got content now.
Lucia: 增加一些动态的打架效果是吧
Lucia: Adding some dynamic fight effects, right?
Katrina:  他那个点外卖了吗
Katrina: Did he order takeout?
Lucia: 哎这是哦
Lucia: Oh, this is it.
Lucia: 我还
Lucia: I still...
Katrina: 就是这个
Katrina: It's this one.
Lucia: 这他这他今天一天开成这样的吗
Lucia: Did he keep it like this all day?
Katrina:  这个东西他会长成这个
Katrina: This thing grows like this.
Lucia: 因为我记得拿出来的时候他还是
Lucia: Because I remember when we took it out, it was...
Lucia: 都还是花苞
Lucia: They were still buds.
Katrina:  对对对他芍药是送的是花球
Katrina: Yeah, yeah, the peonies were delivered as flower balls.
Alice: 嗯然后那个量就是他不能不能太浓
Alice: And the amount, it can't be too concentrated.
Katrina:  嗯这个芍药容易分到6个里面
Katrina: Yeah, these peonies can be divided into six.
Lucia: 太浓了是容易给他扎  虫吗
Lucia: If it's too thick, does it easily attract bugs?
Alice:烧死
Alice: Burn them to death.
Alice:哦OK
Alice: Oh, OK.
Lucia: 我之前养一个水藻
Lucia: 是就是如果加多了会容易长虫
Lucia: If you add too much, it easily attracts bugs.
Lucia: 就是营养过剩然后就
Lucia: It's like, excess nutrients and then...
Katrina:  稍等一下
Katrina: Hold on a second.
Katrina:  他们点外卖了吗
Katrina: Did they order takeout?
Lucia: 好像还没有
Lucia: Seems like they haven't yet.
Alice: 还没点
Alice: They haven't ordered yet.
Alice:我们今天这是录的第几段啊
Alice: How many segments have we recorded today?
Alice: 第二段吧
Alice: The second one, right?
Lucia: 对应该还属于第二段
Lucia: Yeah, this should still be the second one.
Alice: 是不是还有一段
Alice: Do we have another segment?
Lucia: 可能还有一个两个小时
Lucia: Maybe another one or two hours.
Katrina:  但是晚上好像没说啥活动哎
Katrina: But it seems like there's no activity planned for tonight.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Right.
Alice: 明天啥活动
Alice: What's the plan for tomorrow?
Alice: 那怎么有个咖啡啊
Alice: Why is there a coffee?
Lucia: 刚买的吧
Lucia: Probably just bought it.
Alice: 给他归置到哪
Alice: Where should we put it?
Alice: 火锅底料那
Alice: With the hot pot base?
Alice: 那不算可以
Alice: That's not really okay.
Lucia: 因为
Lucia: Because...
Lucia: 因为有一个速溶咖啡在火锅底料里
Lucia: Because there's an instant coffee in the hot pot base.
Katrina:  嗯嗯
Katrina: Mm-hmm.
Katrina: 1234
Katrina: One, two, three, four.
Lucia: 这里面还放了几只
Lucia: There are a few inside here.
Katrina:  哎 12341234是6个
Katrina: Oh, one, two, three, four, one, two, three, four, six total.
Katrina:  6个用一包应该没事吧
Katrina: Six of them should be fine with one pack, right?
Alice: 上面应该有
Alice: Should be written on it.
Alice: 那个浓度多少升
Alice: How many liters for that concentration?
Alice: 配比的那个
Alice: The ratio thing.
Katrina:  0点三liters什么意思
Katrina: 0.3 liters, what does that mean?
Katrina:  呃Rage 0.3升
Katrina: Uh, rage, 0.3 liters.
Jake:l升
Jake: One liter.
Katrina: 哦
Katrina: Oh.
Lucia: 就是300毫升哎
Lucia: That's 300 milliliters.
Lucia: 我觉得咱这个应该稀释
Lucia: I think we should dilute it.
Katrina:  每一包用0.3升的水
Katrina: Use 0.3 liters of water for each pack.
Katrina:  这都有3升了
Katrina: This is already 3 liters.
Lucia: 那那肯定够了
Lucia: Then that's definitely enough.
Alice: 0.3升对这么浓的吗
Alice: 0.3 liters for something this concentrated?
Alice: 他就给了一包哎对哎
Alice: He only gave one packet, right?
Jake: 试一试新买的湿巾纸
Jake: Let's try the new wet wipes I bought.
Katrina:  每包0.3升水是不是
Katrina: Each packet is 0.3 liters, right?
Jake: 嗯这300毫80毫升0.38
Jake: Yeah, this is 300 milliliters, 80 milliliters, 0.38.
Alice: 这么多花
Alice: So many flowers.
Alice: 他才给了一包
Alice: And he only gave one packet.
Katrina:  这也不知道谁的水
Katrina: I don't even know whose water this is.
Katrina:  用来浇花吧哎
Katrina: Let's use it to water the plants.
Alice: 我刚打开的哦
Alice: I just opened it.
Alice: 哈哈哈我以为是我早上的呢
Alice: Haha, I thought it was from this morning.
Jake: 其实是知道的
Jake: Actually, I knew.
Katrina:  哈哈哈想制造冲突是吧哈哈哈
Katrina: Haha, trying to create some conflict, huh? Hahaha.
Jake: 背景音乐来个音效
Jake: Let's add some background music effects.
Lucia: 嘿Siri
Lucia: Hey Siri.
Lucia: 啊让Siri放首歌
Lucia: Ah, let Siri play a song.
Jake:OK
Jake: OK.
Alice: 啊不用洗洁精吗
Alice: Ah, don't we need dish soap?
Jake: 哦对
Jake: Oh, right.
Jake: 外卖咱还没点了
Jake: We haven't ordered takeout yet.
Katrina:  点吧现在有点饿
Jake: 咱午饭没多久但是可以饿
Jake: We just had lunch not long ago, but I guess you can still be hungry.
Katrina:  我感觉我属于那种饱的快
Katrina: I think I'm the type who gets full quickly.
Katrina:  饿的也快那种
Katrina: And gets hungry quickly too.
Katrina: 少吃多餐
Katrina: Small meals throughout the day.
Jake: 呃配乐的
Jake: Uh, for the soundtrack.
Katrina:  这样这样这样这样
Katrina: Like this, like this, like this.
Jake: 这是修硕的
Jake: This is Shure's.
Katrina: 对
Katrina: Yes.
Jake: 对小礼品
Jake: Yeah, a small gift.
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh.
Jake: 这个好像还没有互相送
Jake: This one hasn't been exchanged yet.
Katrina:  没有交换礼物这个环节
Katrina: No gift exchange event yet.
Jake: 有
Jake: There is.
Katrina: 啊对啊对
Katrina: Ah, right, right.
Jake: 我说还没有到
Jake: I mean, it hasn't happened yet.
Alice: 对对我以为要放在后边呢
Alice: Yeah, yeah, I thought it was going to be later.
Jake: 嗯对这个每天都整点小游戏嘛
Jake: Yeah, we do a little game every day.
Alice: 把那个叶子给它捞出来
Alice: Take those leaves out.
Alice: 要不然它会烂
Alice: Otherwise, they'll rot.
Katrina:  哦我感觉我不太懂这边
Katrina: Oh, I feel like I don't quite get this part.
Jake: 就是各位破冰破的太快了
Jake: You guys broke the ice too quickly.
Jake: 一下就破了
Jake: It broke instantly.
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahahaha.
Jake: 哈哈哈感觉不用
Jake: Hahaha, it feels like we don't need...
Lucia: 迅速的熟识了起来
Lucia: ...we got to know each other quickly.
Jake: 对感觉不用什么礼物
Jake: Yeah, it feels like we don't need any gifts.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Katrina:  你看我的压花
Katrina: Look at my pressed flowers.
Katrina:  哇这咖啡真的好苦
Jake: 你们谁先选
Jake: Who wants to choose first?
Jake: 来
Jake: Come on.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
Jake:就是你了
Jake: It's you.
Jake: 选一家
Jake: Pick one.
Lucia: 选个吃的吧
Lucia: Pick something to eat.
Tasha: 私房菜
Tasha: Homemade dishes.
Alice:死亡菜
Alice: Deadly dishes.
Tasha: 私房菜
Tasha: Homemade dishes.
Alice: 哦私房菜
Alice: Oh, homemade dishes.
Jake: 酸菜炖啊
Jake: Pickled vegetable stew?
Tasha: 我没有说要吃这个菜啊
Tasha: I didn't say I wanted to eat that.
Jake: 我知道我知道OK
Jake: I know, I know, OK.
Jake: 哈哈他叫土豆侠子你知道吗
Jake: Haha, he's called Potato Hero, you know?
Alice: 土豆侠子
Alice: Potato Hero?
Lucia: 所以会吃土豆
Lucia: So he eats potatoes.
Jake: 上来给我看一堆土豆
Jake: He showed me a bunch of potatoes.
Alice: 他喜欢土豆
Alice: He likes potatoes.
Jake: 喜欢吃土豆
Jake: Likes eating potatoes.
Tasha: 是的嗯只要花298就可以加入我的土门
Tasha: Yes, you just need to spend 298 to join my potato clan.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Lucia: 但是因为这个所以叫土豆侠子吗
Lucia: But is that why he's called Potato Hero?
Lucia: 啊就是是因为
Lucia: Ah, so it's because...
Lucia: 你是因为喜欢吃土豆
Lucia: ...you like eating potatoes.
Lucia: 所以叫土豆侠子的吗
Lucia: So you're called Potato Hero?
Tasha: 是的
Tasha: Yes.
Lucia: 怎么觉得听起来有点像
Lucia: Sounds a bit like...
Lucia: 一个编出来的理由
Lucia: ...a made-up reason.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Jake: 门店热销土豆红烧肉盖饭就这个吧
Jake: The store's hot-selling braised pork with potatoes rice bowl, let's go with that.
Tasha: 啊每个人吃自己的饭是吗
Tasha: Ah, everyone eats their own meal, right?
Tasha: 哦也可以哦
Tasha: Oh, that works too.
Jake: 你说点这种大菜是吧
Jake: You mean order some big dishes, right?
Tasha: 哦我以为是点大菜
Tasha: Oh, I thought we were ordering big dishes.
Jake: 那每人点一个吧
Jake: Then let's each order one.
Tasha: 每人点一个
Tasha: Each person orders one.
Katrina:  点那种什么肉蟹煲
Katrina: Order that meat and crab pot thing.
Katrina:  什么什么煲里面很多土豆
Katrina: That pot dish with lots of potatoes.
Katrina:  嗯就是他根本就没有那么多肉
Katrina: Hmm, it hardly has any meat at all.
Jake:想象出来的肉蟹煲
Jake: Imaginary meat and crab pot.
Tasha: 不要啥菜啊
Tasha: No vegetables?
Alice: 你点的啥
Alice: What did you order?
Alice: 我点了个水煮肉
Alice: I ordered boiled meat slices.
Tasha: 你不吃猪肉吗
Tasha: You don't eat pork?
Alice: 你认识这个字吗
Alice: Do you recognize this character?
Tasha: 哈哈喂鹅吗
Tasha: Haha, feeding geese?
Katrina:  哇康乃馨花瓣居然要分开吗
Katrina: Wow, do we really have to separate the carnation petals?
Tasha: 这个好用吗
Tasha: Is this useful?
Lucia: 好像还不错的样子
Lucia: Seems pretty good.
Tasha: 哇感觉它好便宜啊面吗
Tasha: Wow, it feels so cheap, noodles?
Lucia: 哎它多少钱
Lucia: Hey, how much is it?
Tasha: 一包九块九
Tasha: 9.9 yuan a pack.
Katrina:  九块九
Katrina:  一 大包
Katrina: A big pack.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Tasha: 我感觉一片就可以把所有的碗都抹了
Tasha: I feel like one sheet can wipe all the bowls.
Lucia: 哈哈哈对对对
Lucia: Haha, yes, yes.
Lucia: 正确用法
Lucia: That's the right way to use it.
Katrina:  想想还有什么
Katrina: Think of anything else?
Lucia: 来看看菜吗姐妹
Lucia: Let's check out the dishes, sisters.
Katrina: 好的
Katrina: Okay.
Katrina:  哦点家常菜是吧
Katrina: Oh, ordering home-style dishes, right?
Alice: 点大餐好像说的是无所谓吧
Alice: Ordering big dishes, I think it's fine either way.
Katrina:  现在点了什么
Katrina: What did Mi order now?
Alice: 嗯麻辣水煮肉
Alice: Hmm, spicy boiled meat slices.
Katrina:  我想吃孜然牛肉
Katrina: I want cumin beef.
Tasha: 冰箱居然没有关
Tasha: The fridge is actually not closed.
Tasha: 没有
Tasha: It's not.
Alice:没关严是吧
Alice: Didn't close it tightly, right?
Katrina:  啊啊看看你们这装满
Katrina: Ah, ah, look at this, it's full.
Katrina:  这上面还有好大的位置哦
Katrina: There's still a lot of space on top.
Katrina:  牛奶在这里
Katrina: The milk is here.
Katrina:  上面全是酒哦
Katrina: The top is all alcohol.
Katrina:  啊养乐多在这
Katrina: Ah, the Yakult is here.
Katrina:  好爽这能不能成为我的家
Katrina: So cool, can this be my home?
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Tasha: 别哈哈哈
Tasha : Stop laughing.
Alice: 唤起你的回忆了
Alice: Does it bring back memories?
Tasha: 你看我的眼睛
Tasha: Look into my eyes.
Tasha: 这里好好热呀
Tasha: It's so hot here.
Katrina:  嗯我也是
Katrina: Yeah, me too.
Katrina:  他工作久了
Katrina: He's been working for a long time.
Alice: 是这是这吗
Alice: Is it this one?
Lucia: 哦对对对
Lucia: Oh, yes, yes.
Lucia: 这个这个
Lucia: This one, this one.
Katrina: 好像直接冲就行了
Katrina: I think you just need to rush in.
Katrina:  哇
Katrina: Wow.
Katrina:  今天我那一小杯就25块钱
Katrina: Today, my small cup is 25 yuan.
Alice:是你最爱的娃娃吗
Alice: Is it your favorite doll?
Katrina: 就是在外面那个咖啡店买的
Katrina: I bought it from that coffee shop outside.
Katrina:  哇好温馨啊
Katrina: Wow, it's so cozy.
Tasha: 都是用钱堆出来的
Tasha: It's all built with money.
Katrina: 对
Katrina: Yeah.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Tasha: 干锅什么
Tasha: What about dry pot?
Alice:娃娃菜
Alice: Baby cabbage.
Alice: 要吗没有没有
Alice: Want it? No, no.
Lucia: 我是说你好像喜欢吃娃娃菜的样子
Lucia: I mean, you seem to like baby cabbage.
Alice:上汤娃娃菜
Alice: Soup baby cabbage.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yes.
Jake: 哎对
Jake: Oh, right.
Jake: 你们晚上是propose的什么活动来着
Jake: What event did you propose for tonight?
Tasha: propose了
Tasha: We proposed.
Jake: 你们是逛超市的时候
Jake: When you were shopping at the supermarket?
Jake: propose的两个什么
Jake: You proposed two things?
Jake: 要做菜做甜点
Jake: Cooking and making dessert?
Jake: 做半个小时甜点
Jake: Making dessert for half an hour?
Tasha: 可以啊
Tasha: Sure!
Jake:OK
Jake: OK
Alice: 你为啥不点土豆啊
Alice: Why didn't you order potatoes?
Alice: 我给你点上吧
Alice: I'll order them for you.
Alice: 哈哈排骨土豆炖豆角
Alice: Haha, pork ribs, potatoes, and beans stew.
Alice: 还有啥土豆啊
Alice: What other potato dishes?
Alice: 给你找都
Alice: I'll find them for you.
Tasha: 都可以都可以
Tasha: Anything is fine.
Alice: 排骨土豆
Alice: Pork ribs and potatoes.
Tasha: 要不要吃回锅肉
Tasha: How about twice-cooked pork?
Alice: 那你不要你的土豆了
Alice: Then you won't have your potatoes.
Tasha: 可以不要
Tasha: That's fine.
Tasha: 哈哈回锅肉
Tasha: Haha, twice-cooked pork.
Tasha: 锅包肉锅包肉
Tasha: Sweet and sour pork.
Jake: 白板担当
Jake: The whiteboard is ready.
Katrina:  嗯哼哼
Katrina: Mm-hmm.
Tasha: 锅包肉回锅肉
Tasha: Sweet and sour pork, twice-cooked pork.
Katrina:  是我们四个
Katrina: It's the four of us.
Katrina:  还带他一起吗
Katrina: Are we bringing him along?
Katrina:  一起的是吧
Katrina: Together, right?
Lucia: 对我们一起四个菜
Lucia: Yes, the four of us together.
Katrina:  三荤一素
Tasha: 哦有素菜吗
Tasha: Oh, is there a veggie dish?
Tasha: 我们没有点过素菜
Tasha: We never order veggie dishes.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Alice: 你俩想吃哪个你点两个啊
Alice: Which one do you two want to eat? You order two.
Lucia: 或者或者或者番茄牛腩
Lucia: Or, or, or tomato beef stew.
Lucia: 里面有番茄
Lucia: It has tomatoes.
Lucia: 哈哈是吧
Lucia: Haha, right?
Lucia: 姑且算是半个素菜
Lucia: It kind of counts as a half veggie dish.
Tasha: 素菜里面要一个手撕包菜
Tasha: For veggies, let's have hand-shredded cabbage.
Tasha: 或者要一个酸辣土豆丝 哈哈
Tasha: Or spicy shredded potatoes. Haha.
Katrina: 可以
Katrina: Sounds good.
Tasha:  68 42
Tasha: 68, 42.
Tasha: 哈哈现在开始煮汤
Tasha: Haha, now let's start making the soup.
Alice: 今天晚上就喝吧
Alice: Let's drink it tonight.
Tasha: 是吧 是今天晚上开始做汤吗
Tasha: Right? Are we making the soup tonight?
Tasha: 反正吃家常菜吗
Tasha: Anyway, it's just homemade food.
Alice:可能吧
Alice: Maybe.
Katrina:  装入密封袋
Katrina: Put it in a sealed bag.
Tasha: 现在是7点半
Tasha: It's 7:30 now.
Katrina:  那我试验一下压花效果
Katrina: Let me try out the embossing effect.
Katrina:  今天晚上开会吗
Katrina: Are we having a meeting tonight?
Alice: 点这个吧
Alice: Click this one.
Alice: 我不太想吃猪
Alice: I don't really want to eat pork.
Alice: 可以吗
Alice: Is that okay?
Tasha: 可以啊可以
Tasha: Sure, sure.
Jake: 我自己要开会
Jake: I have my own meeting.
Katrina:  我可能有点事
Katrina: I might have something to do.
Alice: 那我们开始做吧
Alice: Then let's start.
Alice: 你让他点
Alice: Let him choose.
Katrina:  摘两片芍药花瓣
Katrina: Pick two peony petals.
Tasha: 神圣的交接仪
Tasha: The sacred handover ceremony.
Alice: 来吧我们开始吧
Alice: Come on, let's begin.
Tasha: 好我们开始吧
Tasha: Okay, let's start.
Alice: 我们几个人做汤的话需要
Alice: For the soup, we need...
Tasha: 你需要一个配手
Tasha: You need an assistant.
Tasha: 我需要一个配手
Tasha: I need an assistant.
Tasha: 是吗
Tasha: Right?
Alice:我不需要哦
Alice: I don't need one.
Alice: 我自己给自己打下手
Alice: I'll handle it myself.
Jake: 牛啊
Jake: Impressive.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
Katrina:  好 需要我帮忙吗
Katrina: Alright, do you need my help?
Alice: 我们需要做多少量呢
Alice: How much do we need to make?
Tasha: 嗯嗯一人一碗的量就行
Tasha: Hmm, just enough for one bowl each.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Alice:一人一碗是
Katrina: 汤就
Alice: 一点点也没什么对多少应该
Alice: A little bit more won't hurt.
Katrina: 汤一人一碗应该没问题
Alice: 那我把我戒指取下来
Alice: I'll take off my ring then.
Lucia: 哈哈哈等待指派中
Lucia: Hahaha, waiting for instructions.
Tasha: 等一下
Tasha: Wait a minute.
Jake:我问一下谢明珠来不来
Jake: Let me check if Xie Mingzhu is coming.
Jake: 他有可能来
Jake: He might come.
Jake: 来的话就多加点
Jake: If he comes, we'll need to make more.
Tasha: 哎米饭是不是没点
Tasha: Hey, did we order rice?
Tasha: 谁来谢冰珠
Tasha: Who's Xie Bingzhu?
Lucia: 哈哈哈吓一跳
Lucia: Hahaha, that scared me.
Jake:害怕
Jake: Frightening.
Tasha: 好的你先开始
Tasha: Okay, you start first.
小汾：嗯好香啊
Katrina:  到底是哪种花香
Katrina: What kind of flower scent is it?
Katrina:  大
Katrina: Big.
Katrina:  掉出来了掉出来了
Katrina: It fell out, it fell out.
Katrina:  哎呀
Katrina: Oh no.
Katrina:  这是干啥的
Katrina: What's this for?
Katrina: 有啥要要我帮忙的不
Katrina: Is there anything you need help with?
Katrina:  嗯i can我已经free了
Katrina: Hmm, I can, I'm already free.
Katrina:  我看看我这压花
Katrina: Let me see, my flower press.
Katrina:  这两天能压出什么东西
Katrina: What can I press out in these two days?
Katrina:  哈哈哈先尝试一个
Katrina: Hahaha, let's try one first.
Katrina:  我已经压了一个
Katrina: I've already pressed one.
Katrina:  不是我那个板
Katrina: Not my board.
Katrina:  就是那个压花板
Katrina: It's that flower press board.
Katrina:  我已经放了几片花瓣进去了
Katrina: I've already put a few petals in.
Katrina:  不知道压出来什么效果
Katrina: Don't know what the result will be.
Katrina:  它不是也要两三天吗
Katrina: Doesn't it take two or three days?
Jake: 嗯伤腰啊
Jake: Hmm, hurts my back.
Katrina:  没事年轻的
Katrina: It's okay, you're young.
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈好嘞 好嘞
Jake: Hahaha, alright, alright.
Tasha: 他在说你
Tasha: He's talking about you.
Jake: 对确实
Jake: Yeah, true.
Katrina:  今天下午坐地上插了花然后也压了
Katrina: This afternoon I sat on the ground arranging flowers and pressing them too.
Tasha: 这个压
Tasha: This press...
Tasha: 我一开始是想让你也带一双的
Tasha: I initially wanted you to bring a pair too.
Alice:哎呀
Alice: Oh no.
Katrina:  来吧我帮你吧
Katrina: Come on, let me help you.
Alice:我需要一点热水
Alice: I need some hot water.
Katrina: 就帮你烧一壶开水
Katrina: I'll boil a kettle for you.
Alice: 呃两升左右
Alice: About two liters.
Katrina: 这是多少
Katrina: How much is this?
Alice: 没关系多了也没事
Alice: It's okay if it's more.
Lucia: 让我来
Lucia: Let me do it.
Katrina: 这应该没有两升
Katrina: This should be less than two liters.
Katrina:  这是做什么汤来着
Katrina: What soup is this for?
Katrina: 我怎么没听过这是哪个地方的菜吗
Katrina: Why haven't I heard of this dish, where's it from?
Katrina: 坏的蛋
Katrina: A bad egg.
Alice: 异类的东西
Alice: Something unusual.
Katrina:  都会觉得这发霉了
Katrina: People would think this is moldy.
Alice: 这其实是一种很好吃的蛋
Alice: Actually, this is a really delicious egg.
Alice: 屏幕前的朋友们
Alice: Friends in front of the screen,
Alice: 如果你们有机会来中国的话
Alice: If you get the chance to come to China,
Katrina: 哈哈哈 外国朋友们
Katrina: Hahaha, foreign friends,
Katrina:  没有水位线
Katrina: There's no water level.
Alice:  哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahaha
Lucia: 不不我要把手先擦一下
Lucia: No, no, I need to wipe my hands first.
Katrina:  对打鸡蛋吗
Katrina: Are we breaking the eggs?
Tasha: 呃先把盆擦一下
Tasha: Uh, wipe the bowl first.
Tasha: 然后再打鸡蛋
Tasha: Then break the eggs.
Tasha: 稍等把鸡蛋给他喝
Tasha: Hold on, give him the egg to drink.
Tasha: 对就是我碰无菌的东西
Tasha: Yeah, I touch sterile things,
Tasha: 你碰有菌的东西
Tasha: You touch non-sterile things.
Tasha: 这样子我们就可以保证食材的干净
Tasha: This way we can ensure the ingredients are clean.
Katrina:  嘿嘿非常的专业
Katrina: Hehe, very professional.
Katrina:  哇有花的房间就是不一样
Katrina: Wow, a room with flowers is different.
Katrina:  拍出来可好看了
Katrina: It looks great in photos.
Katrina:  纸杯蛋糕
Katrina: Cupcakes.
Katrina:  好好看呀这个光打上
Katrina: It looks amazing with this lighting.
Tasha: 啊啊坏了
Tasha: Ah, it's ruined.
Tasha: 呃重做了
Tasha: Uh, redo it.
Tasha: 要重新打蛋了
Tasha: We have to break the eggs again.
Lucia:啊
Lucia: Ah.
Tasha: 嗯对
Tasha: Yeah, right.
Katrina: 怎么了
Katrina: What happened?
Alice: 我们今天是不是得吃炒鸡蛋了宝
Alice: Are we going to eat scrambled eggs today, babe?
Tasha: 嗯他不
Tasha: Hmm, he doesn't...
Tasha: 他要打的很低才行啊
Tasha: He needs to beat it very low.
Lucia: 要多我我觉得这样
Lucia: More, I think like this.
Lucia: 因为我感觉再往下
Lucia: Because I feel if we go lower,
Lucia: 好像蛋壳会碰到这个
Lucia: The eggshell might touch the egg white.
Lucia: 蛋清嗯嗯
Lucia: The egg white, mm-hmm.
Tasha: 流出来就失败了哦
Tasha: If it spills out, it's a fail.
Lucia: 啊这为什么
Lucia: Ah, why is this?
Katrina:  为什么嗯
Katrina: Why, hmm?
Tasha: 蛋清蛋黄不能分离了哦
Tasha: The egg white and yolk can't be separated.
Katrina:  你买那个就是分离蛋清
Katrina: You bought that egg white separator.
Tasha: 分离蛋清气不好用哦
Tasha: The egg white separator doesn't work well.
Katrina:  我之前看那个综艺谁
Katrina: I saw that variety show where...
Katrina:  我也不太会打蛋了
Tasha: 好那下一次吧
Alice: 嗯又又又又变成这个了
Tasha:: 呃我算了
Alice: 没关系吧
Katrina:  哇好像个实验台
Lucia: 那我们这个
Lucia: 哈哈这个蛋蛋他怎么办
Lucia: 要不炒了吧
Katrina:  本来要做成什么
Katrina:  做蛋糕
Lucia: 哦对
Katrina:  拿一个小饮料喝
Katrina:  哎呀牛奶怎翻了
Tasha: 下一个鸡蛋
Lucia: 下一个鸡蛋在哪
Tasha: 两个在那里
Tasha: 在那里哪个
Lucia: 呃这里面
Lucia: 哦OK
Katrina:  我是一个爱拍照的人
Katrina: I'm someone who loves taking pictures.
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈哈哈惨遭滑铁卢的经验
Katrina: Hahaha, it's the experience of a total failure.
Lucia: 磕蛋磕蛋磕得太用力了
Lucia: 没事没事
Lucia: It's okay, it's okay.
Lucia: 那我们先
Lucia: So, we first...
Katrina: 炒吧
Katrina: Stir-fry it.
Lucia: 无所谓把那个把那个午餐肉喝了
Lucia: No worries, just drink that luncheon meat.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哎
Tasha: Haha, oh dear.
Lucia: 啊里面的午餐肉呢
Lucia: Ah, where's the luncheon meat?
Lucia: 我们是做别的菜用了吗
Lucia: Did we use it for another dish?
Alice: 是吗到了外面去
Alice: Really? Did it go outside?
Katrina:  哎所以我们刚才点点点外卖了吗
Katrina: So did we just order delivery earlier?
Tasha: 点了
Tasha: We did.
Lucia: 点了的话那今天再炒个蛋
Lucia: If we ordered, then let's fry another egg today.
Lucia: 能吃完不
Lucia: Can we finish it?
Lucia: 要不我把这蛋给他炒了算了
Lucia: Or should I just fry this egg for him?
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Alice:因为比较硬
Alice: Because it's a bit hard.
Tasha: 简直不敢相信
Tasha: I can't believe it.
Tasha: 我要是
Lucia: 那你需要换个手套或者之类的吗
Lucia: Do you need to change gloves or something?
Alice: 还是家人们
Alice: Or family members?
Katrina:  这谁的手机
Katrina: Whose phone is this?
Katrina:  这壁纸好好看
Katrina: This wallpaper is so pretty.
Lucia: 我的嗯
Lucia: It's mine, yeah.
Lucia: 我还拿了一个i'm Libbo
Lucia: I also got an "I'm Libbo."
Lucia: 虽然我拿了
Lucia: Although I got...
Lucia: 多少蛋啊
Lucia: How many eggs?
Lucia: 两盒吗不知道
Lucia: Two boxes? Not sure.
Lucia: 好像是两盒
Lucia: Seems like two boxes.
Tasha: 是的
Tasha: Yes.
Katrina:  做做做那个小蛋糕应该还要蛮多的
Katrina: Making those small cakes will need quite a lot.
Lucia: 这次很成功
Lucia: This time was very successful.
Lucia: 好厉害啊
Lucia: So impressive.
Lucia: 哈哈不敢相信
Lucia: Haha, I can't believe it.
Tasha: 哇
Tasha: Wow.
Katrina:  好可爱的蛋
Katrina: Such cute eggs.
Tasha: 完了这个蛋清
Tasha: Oh no, this egg white...
Tasha: 嗯就这个也不要
Tasha: Yeah, we don't need this either.
Lucia: 好了那个
Lucia: Alright, then...
Lucia: 那样的话没有问题吗
Lucia: Is it okay like that?
Tasha: 嗯对蛋黄里面
Tasha: Yeah, for the egg yolk.
Tasha: 没关系蛋蛋清里面一定要是纯蛋清
Tasha: It's fine, but the egg white must be pure egg white.
Tasha: 嗯行再拿两个
Tasha: Okay, let's get two more.
Alice: 哈哈哈我们今天一共买了多少蛋啊
Alice: Hahaha, how many eggs did we buy today?
Tasha: 嗯好吧我们下次买便宜蛋吧哈哈
Tasha: Hmm, okay, next time we'll buy cheaper eggs, haha.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Alice: 没关系的
Alice: It's alright.
Tasha: 没关系，今天肯定是第一次
Tasha: It's okay, today is definitely the first time.
Katrina:  whoa啊
Katrina: Whoa.
Katrina:  又成功了
Katrina: It worked again.
Tasha: 不敢相信
Tasha: Can't believe it.
Tasha: 好厉害
Tasha: So impressive.
Alice: 好我再重复一次
Alice: Okay, let me repeat it again.
Katrina: 好可爱的鸡蛋
Katrina: Such cute eggs.
Katrina: 哎嘿嘿嘿嘿嘿
Katrina: Hehehehe.
Alice: 我妈做皮蛋瘦肉粥很好喝但是哇
Alice: My mom makes really good century egg and lean pork congee, but wow...
Katrina:  我超级喜欢吃皮蛋瘦肉粥
Katrina: I love eating century egg and lean pork congee.
Alice: 她切皮蛋的时候也是像现在一样恶心
Alice: When she cuts the century eggs, it's just as gross as now.
Katrina:  你可以拍一个第一视角的vlog
Katrina: You can shoot a first-person view vlog.
Lucia: yes
Lucia: Yes.
Tasha: 把这个拿到冰箱里面
Tasha: Put this in the fridge.
Tasha: 呃楼上冰箱吧
Tasha: Uh, the fridge upstairs.
Tasha: 因为这已经放不下了
Tasha: Because there's no more room here.
Tasha: 冷冻10分钟
Tasha: Freeze it for 10 minutes.
Tasha: 冷藏10分钟
Tasha: Chill it for 10 minutes.
Lucia: 冷藏10分钟
Lucia: Chill it for 10 minutes.
Tasha: 就可以OK了
Tasha: Then it should be fine.
Alice: 这个切菜的过程中
Alice: During the chopping process,
Alice: 我放了一点可乐的
Alice: I added a little bit of cola.
Alice: 我觉得这个我可能挺
Alice: I think this might be quite...
Jake: 什么东西
Jake: What is it?
Jake: 大成功
Jake: A great success.
Tasha: 是的你很爱自言自语是吗
Tasha: Yeah, you love talking to yourself, don't you?
Katrina:  啊刚刚打鸡蛋成功哈哈
Katrina: Ah, I just successfully cracked the egg, haha.
Jake: 打鸡蛋打成功
Jake: You cracked the egg successfully.
Katrina:  这可以放心
Katrina: You can rest assured.
Katrina:  主要是因为失败了好几次哈哈
Katrina: Mainly because I failed several times, haha.
Lucia: 哎这个不行这个这个也得抹一下
Lucia: Hey, this won't work, this needs to be wiped too.
Katrina: 把 把这个
Katrina: Move this, move this...
Katrina: 移到下边
Katrina: To the lower part.
Katrina:  哇
Katrina: Wow.
Alice: 棒棒，现在刚好放下
Alice: Great, now it fits just right.
Lucia: 现在是几点钟
Lucia: What time is it now?
Tasha: 我手上好像有点蛋清清姐妹看一下
Tasha: I think I have some egg whites on my hand, sisters, look.
Katrina: 57
Katrina: 57.
Tasha: 67
Tasha: 67.
Katrina:  67
Katrina: 67.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Katrina: amazing
Katrina: Amazing.
Alice: 逐渐暴躁起来了
Alice: I'm getting gradually more irritated.
Alice: 讨厌切皮蛋
Alice: I hate cutting century eggs.
Tasha: 居然不够用了啥
Tasha: We're actually running out, what?
Katrina:  什么东西呀
Katrina: What is it?
Katrina:  哦他有这么多
Katrina: Oh, there's so much.
Tasha: 没有这么多哎
Tasha: There's not that much.
Tasha: 就放这吧先
Tasha: Just leave it here for now.
Katrina:  绞鸡蛋有什么技巧吗
Katrina: Is there any trick to beating eggs?
Tasha: 呃绞鸡蛋没有什么技巧
Tasha: Uh, there's no trick to beating eggs.
Katrina:  我帮你绞吧
Katrina: I'll help you beat it.
Alice: 就同一个方向
Alice: Just in the same direction.
Alice: 是同一个方向绞就行了
Alice: As long as you beat it in the same direction, it's fine.
Katrina:  特别想绞鸡蛋
Katrina: I really want to beat the eggs.
Tasha: 呃等一下
Tasha: Uh, wait a second.
Katrina: 我洗个手
Katrina: I'll wash my hands.
Alice: 你我讨厌红楼梦里小雅默默
Alice: I hate Xiao Ya from Dream of the Red Chamber.
Lucia: OK擦干
Lucia: OK, dry it.
Alice: 再擦一遍
Alice: Dry it again.
Tasha:: 对因为只有一个对吧
Tasha: Yeah, because there's only one, right?
Tasha: 资金有限
Tasha: Limited budget.
Alice: 其实做菜的时候真的没有很满足就是
Alice: Actually, cooking doesn't really satisfy me.
Lucia: 好害怕我擦擦把这个纸落在里面
Lucia: I'm so afraid I'll leave pieces of this paper in there.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Tasha: 所以呃
Tasha: So, uh,
Tasha: 所以如果做烘焙的话
Tasha: So if we're baking,
Tasha: 会买那种厨房用纸
Tasha: We should buy kitchen paper.
Tasha: 可以擦干很多遍的那个
Tasha: The kind you can dry things with multiple times.
Lucia: 就是那个吸吸吸水纸那种对
Lucia: The absorbent paper, right?
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yes.
Katrina:  这是什么
Katrina: What's this?
Lucia: 我以前拿那个光光拿它擦锅灶
Lucia: I used to use it to wipe the stove.
Katrina: 哦，玉米呦
Katrina: Oh, corn.
Katrina:  你你这个是要做要做什么来着
Katrina: What, what are you going to make with this?
Katrina:  就小蛋糕吗
Katrina: Just a small cake?
Tasha: 嗯就做一个最简单的就行吧
Tasha: Yeah, just make the simplest one.
Katrina: 哦
Katrina: Oh.
Katrina:  那就是先打鸡蛋
Katrina: So, start with the eggs.
Lucia:  先乳化
Lucia: First, emulsify.
Alice: 逐渐暴躁
Alice: Gradually getting irritated.
Alice: 我真的讨厌切皮蛋啊
Alice: I really hate cutting century eggs.
Tasha: 先给给我一个筷子啊
Tasha: First, give me a chopstick.
Katrina:  这样就这样吧
Katrina: Just like this, right?
Alice: 好保持平静
Alice: Okay, stay calm.
Alice: 心情平静
Alice: Keep calm.
Katrina:  这个是只需要蛋黄
Katrina: This only needs egg yolks.
Tasha: 对用蛋黄
Tasha: Yes, use the egg yolks.
Lucia: 好像应该
Lucia: I think we should.
Lucia: 我觉得差不多了
Lucia: I think it's almost done.
Lucia: 不过外面还有点水小心
Lucia: But there's still some water outside, be careful.
Tasha: 然后加28克的玉米油
Tasha: Then add 28 grams of corn oil.
Alice: 你说讨厌红楼梦里  恶心
Alice: You said you hate "Dream of the Red Chamber", it's disgusting.
Katrina:  放点歌吧
Katrina: Let's play some music.
Alice: 大东北
Alice: Big Northeast.
Katrina:  我知道你刚刚唱那首歌
Katrina: I know the song you just sang.
Katrina:  是不是讨厌红楼梦
Katrina: Do you hate "Dream of the Red Chamber"?
Alice: 对对对哎呀天呐
Alice: Yeah, yeah, oh my gosh.
Alice: 受不了了
Alice: I can't stand it.
Katrina:  天啊
Katrina: Oh my gosh.
Alice: 讨厌红楼梦
Alice: Hate "Dream of the Red Chamber".